ja so ist es vorausschicken musste ich
wieder in ganz seltsamen zeiten
inzwischen zeiten ein interregio ist
angebrochen wir haben noch eine
geschäftsführende
bundesregierung und eine neue kommt
gerade unter schmerzlichen weg zustande
und im sondierungs papier heißt der
erste satz die nächsten jahre sind
entscheidend um deutschland und europa
zu stärken ja schön wäre es wenn man
daraus auch konsequenzen ziehen würde
und weiter heißt es wir werden die
europäische union stärken ob unserer
verantwortung zu entsprechen meine
befürchtung ist man wird dieser
verantwortung wenn man das macht was man
vorhat gerade nicht entsprechen um es
klar zu sagen die deutsche
migrationspolitik ist eine gefahr für
europa sie war es schon in der spätphase
merkel sie wird es vermutlich in der
ampel zeit erst recht sein denn wir
sehen ja an der grenze zwischen
weißrussland und polen werden von dem
schleuser diktator lukaschenko geplant
migranten an die eu außengrenze gebracht
die eu ist mehr oder minder unwillig die
außengrenze zu schützen man lässt polen
allein der türkei dann geholfen holen
lässt man allein und hat heute kamen
dazu die frischen zahlen vom bundesamt
für migration und flüchtlinge im
bisherige richter also januar bis
oktober wurden 115.000 erstanträge vom
bundesamt auf asyl entgegengenommen
anstieg von fast 40 prozent dann hat
damit fast wieder das vorkrisenniveau
erreicht das heißt eine regierung eine
neue regierung muss sich ehrlich machen
an der außengrenze in der europapolitik
in der migrationspolitik und muss sagen
wenn wir europa erhalten wollen dann
müssen wir die grenzen schützen
und das besondere eigentlich an der
situation die wir jetzt haben es ja eine
ein bisschen ein déjà vu
2015 also nicht ganz so starkes der
antrag aber das ist ja eine art der neue
balkanroute die hier bis nach berlin
führt also über minsk das erstaunliche
ist doch dass er jetzt gar nicht mehr
darüber gesprochen wird also vor sechs
jahren hat man sich noch ordentlich
darüber gestritten
es war im wahlkampf kein thema es ist in
den koalitionsverhandlungen allenfalls
phasenweise so wie sie es gesagt haben
angesprochen worden aber die probleme
werden nicht gelöst und vor allen dingen
ist es ja auch die frage wen wollen wir
eigentlich aufnehmen und wie viel und
dass das nicht mehr dass das nicht mehr
diskutiert wird das ist glaube ich ganz
genau diese frage ist ja tabuisiert und
wird mutmaßlich unter der neuen ampel
regierung noch weiter tab überhaupt
warum ihnen wollten wir auf die frage
tabuisiert weil das die leute nicht
gestellt wenn wir aber die journalisten
stellen ist der führende politiker
stellen und um auch aus der csu zum
beispiel alexander dobrindt hat das
zuletzt mal wieder auf es geht ein
bisschen hin und her gibt manchmal so
den konvertiten schache feinermann grad
langeweile wir haben da auf dem
parlament ja die ausstellung ist völlig
jenseits einer regierungs oder
handlungsoption ist die frage wird
deshalb von den handelnden akteuren
nicht gestellt weil man sein selbstbild
eben gegen alle realität aufrecht
aufrechterhalten will dh wir sind eine
humanistische nation und deshalb
verwehren wir keinem den zugang einem
der nur das wort asyl sagen kann auch
wenn schon beim grenzübertritt klar ist
hat kein recht eigentlich hier dauerhaft
zu leben man ist also möglich gewählt um
den preis der realitätsverleugnung und
dem preis auch einen nachhaltigen
schädigung des eigenen landes diese
frage ist es nicht zu stellen sich nicht
ehrlich zu machen und lieber diesem
wolkenkuckucksheim einer obergrenzen
aufnahmemöglichkeit zu folgen cool aber
dass wir aufpassen dass man hier jetzt
nicht
asylrecht und migrationsrecht vermischt
das hatte ich einmal noch an sagt aber
das wird gemacht das heißt auf der
flucht migration heißt regierungspapier
flucht micra gut aber man weiß ja wenn
man an der grenze sind es jetzt leute
die asyl beantragen die schutzsuchend
sind oder mir geht es hier um migration
dass das problem oder leute dass ich
getan das problem ist dass die migration
über das asylrecht funktioniert also das
heißt die leute wissen es gibt übrigens
muss man dazu sagen sehr viele leute die
aus wirklicher not kommen das wollen wir
ja wirklich nicht ignorieren ja also auf
keinen fall und auch politisch verfolgte
das problem ist aber dass wenn wir an
die grenze gehen zu polen oder zu
deutschland also an eine eu grenze und
sagen asyl dürfen wir rein und da keinen
anderen umständen sie dürfen nicht rein
wenn sie sagen ich bin krank sie wird
dürfen nicht rein wenn sie sagen ich
habe da meine großmutter oder ich will
ein auto kaufen sie dürfen einfach nicht
in diese länder rein aber wenn sie asyl
sagen ja also und das würde ich dann
auch machen sagen die leute asyl dann
kommen sie ins asylverfahren und dann
wird entschieden ob sie asyl bekommen
wird abgelehnt da muss auch als auch im
management verfahren oder ist das nicht
eigentlich die lösung also ich meine das
ist ja auch genau die diskussion die wir
auch hatten mit
nach fälligen flüchtlingen ja dass er
nicht konsequent genug nach management
italien zurückschicken also sieht zum
beispiel das aktuelle problem was wir
haben mit weißrussland es gibt ein
rücknahme vertrag mit minsk berlin minsk
von juni 2020 der wird von der
bundesrepublik nicht angewendet das
heißt alle die über mindesten sind und
hier abgelehnt werden müssten eigentlich
zurückgeschickt werden da bin ich mal
aber wir wissen ja ganz klar dass in
diesem fall eine regierung in diesem
weißrussland und ein regime eigentlichen
druck aus der eu mit diesem menschen
ausüben will wir wissen dass die leute
eigentlich nicht aus dem lot kommen
sondern sie werden als eine politische
macht sozusagen ausgenutzt und
instrumentalisiert und trotzdem sind wir
nicht in der lage klarer kante zu sagen
und zu sagen ja natürlich leute die
schutz suchen die schutz brauchen
verdienen eine asyl auch hier in
deutschland ich bin stolz in einem land
zu sein wo menschen aufgenommen werden
wenn sie es brauchen aber in diesem fall
das kann man etwas kann man nicht so
schnell herausfinden also wenn wir jetzt
mal den fall nehmen ich komme aus
afghanistan oder syrien oder aus dem
irak nach belarus und dann werde ich und
absolut richtig sozusagen gesammelt über
die grenze geschoben wenn jetzt einer
von denjenigen an der grenze zu
deutschland sagt ich brauche asyl oder
ich muss asyl bekommen weil ich werde
verfolgt dann kann ja nicht der
grenzbeamte der bundespolizei beamte an
der grenze sagen nein meine
papiere reichen nicht oder auch der
polnische könnte das nicht worüber man
sprechen kann ist ob sozusagen
diejenigen überhaupt und weiter nach
deutschland dürfen weil eigentlich
müssten sie in polen bleiben aber es
muss ja eine untersuchung geben es muss
ein geordnetes verfahren geben weshalb
ist nicht so einfach ist glaube ich
sozusagen flüchtlings suchende
direkt einzuteilen und zu sagen der darf
und er darf nicht und wenn wir über
obwohl geht eigentlich darum darf oder
nicht darf es geht nicht darum diese
verfahren so schnell wie möglich zu
machen damit diejenigen die wirklich
asyl auch rechte haben das ist vorbild
aller nicht ein gutes vorbild ist mich
das flughafenverfahren das vergessen wir
immer es kommen ja auch migranten oder
flüchtlinge an unseren flughäfen an und
da gibt es ein schnellverfahren
und da gibt es eine unterbringung in den
großen flughäfen und da wird innerhalb
von wenigen tagen entschieden ob ein
asylverfahren in aussicht steht
überhaupt und wer nicht werden diese
leute wieder ins flugzeug gesetzt
warum funktioniert das nicht an den
außengrenzen der eu recht schaffen wir
haben weniger einen migrations problem
als ein produkt aktiv am leben weil
dieser ganzen geschichte oder hat
natürlich aber auch einen ein
umsetzungsproblem hat uns doch immer
gesagt und da würde ich auch dann
festhalten wir haben erst einmal binnen
freiheit innerhalb europas im schengen
raum weil wir die außengrenzen schützen
jetzt ist polen bereits räume zu bauen
aus purer not und wird deshalb moralisch
an den senkel gestellt es ist eine außen
christiane sehr interessant ist das
interessante freiheit geßler ich hab
mich verwundert die süddeutsche zeitung
gelesen in dieser woche und selbst dort
im kommentar hat man den mauerbau auf in
polen unterstützt und hat gesagt das sei
der richtige schritt und seltsam dass
die eu das die unterstützung frau von
der leyen sowas sagt wir brauchen keine
mauer und keine zäune und den
geschichtlichen vergleich herstellt also
warum ist es denn selbst ja eher
linksorientierte zeitung diese diesen
zorn oder diese mauer für für richtige
achten das ist ein stimmungsbild als
beispiel warum ist es aus ihrer sicht so
schwierig da auch verständnis für polen
zu entwickeln ich hatte zunächst mal
schöne einzelnen stimme ist wundert mich
ja dass die süddeutsche zeitung
lernfähig ist ich glaube der konsens ist
schon ganz anders wehrmauern baut der
der markt keine menschen so heißt ja
ganz platt runtergebrochen dann heißt
dann immer wir wollen diese bilder nicht
haben wir wollen europa nicht zur
festung machen wir wollen keinen
stacheldraht haben obwohl vermutlich
einen stacheldrahtzaun gar nicht
funktioniert und letzten endes führt
kein weg daran vorbei europa ist keine
festung aber es muss sich bei einem so
ungeregelten ansturm verhalten als wäre
es eine festung die freiheiten im innen
zu sichern und wenn wir nicht in der
lage ist die außengrenzen zu schützen
dann müssen eben übergaben sie den
glauben sie wirklich dass man sich mit
einer mauer abschotten kann ich kann
mich erinnern ab 2016 glaube ich war es
von der mauer zwischen den oder der dem
mauerbau zwischen mexiko und den usa
berichtet und selbst in den bereichen wo
es diese mauer gab sind flüchtlinge doch
immer irgendwie durch gekommen ja also
ist es ja nicht so dass eine mauer sie
kommt schützen na ja aber das ist eine
notlösung also erst mal keiner will eine
mauer übrigens gerade die grenze
zwischen polen und weißrussland die
menschen am allerwenigsten
das war ja früher alles polen nicht dass
also auch weil weißrussland diese leute
leben alle sehr eng zusammen die wollen
es recht es ist eine notlösung aber sie
funktioniert ja wir schauen uns an
spanien hat eine scheune gezogen in
afrika wie heißt die enklave ich hab sie
gerade nicht wenn den top sechs meter
hoch zwei reich griechenland hat einen
eine art mauer gebaut einen gigantischen
sound so türkei litauen baut eine mauer
die ukraine denkt daran ihm da wo die
bereits stehen funktioniert es doch ja
muss man so sagen ich bin mir sicher
kaufen es ist so traurig es ist aber es
gibt sozusagen es gibt gar keine andere
möglichkeit wenn man einwanderung
steuern möchte und wenn man sich
entscheiden möchte wie man das uns noch
einmal sagen die leute die jetzt über
linz gekommen die können sich
flugtickets leisten und zahlen 10.000
euro bis ich hier sind das ist sozusagen
die creme de la creme der flüchtlinge
die ganz armen leute die kommen doch gar
nicht die frage ob wir alle noch